et installations aujourd'hui du comité
opérationnel de lutte contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme dans le département
une structure qui permettra de traduire
sur le terrain la politique du
gouvernement dans ce domaine éducation
répression face notamment aux 23 actes
répertoriés dans les yvelines et en 2015
on notera ainsi les 42 procédure engagée
l'an dernier au parquet de versailles
pour diffamation et injures en région en
raison de la race la religion ou encore
la nation d'origine le gouvernement
entend ne laisser aucun incident sans
suite il entend aussi former les
citoyens comme vous allez l'entendre là
je vous donne un exemple le ministère de
l'éducation nationale a mis en ligne un
site portail de ressources
pour pouvoir justement parler de ces
choses là avec des fiches pratiques la
laïcité comment parler de la liberté
d'expression comme en ont parlé pourquoi
on dit racisme et antisémitisme toutes
ces questions là vous prenez un public
d'âge scolaire quel que soit le lieu
quel que soit le moment ces questions
sont posées donc il faut pouvoir y
répondre parce que si on n'y répond pas
avec de bonnes réponses avec de bons
outils avec des repères historiques
juridiques et autres on peut être
certain que sur les réseaux sociaux sur
internet on va trouver des réponses et
ce sera pas toujours les bonnes